From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. So a couple of weeks ago, I was calling principals and teachers to find out what it was like to be in schools.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。几周前，我给校长和老师们打电话，想了解学校里的现状。
I called Principal Brian Cox in Wyoming. Did he have a minute to talk?
我给怀俄明州的Brian Cox校长打了电话。他有时间聊聊吗？
Um, I can, yeah. I've got to be out on bus duty in, like, 15 minutes.
嗯，可以。我大概15分钟后得去负责校车调度。
Principal Cox normally does not do bus duty. He also does not normally teach French class, because he's a principal, and he doesn't know French. He did both the week we spoke, because 20% of his staff were absent. Omicron.
Cox校长平时不用负责校车。他平时也不教法语课，因为他是校长，而且他不懂法语。但在我们通话的那一周，他两样都干了，因为他手下20%的员工缺勤了。因为奥密克戎。
You know, I told somebody today when we walked in-- we had three paraprofessionals down in very key special education classrooms-- and I told them our goal today is to be a hockey goalie and just keep it out of the net.
你知道，我今天刚跟人说过——我们有三名关键特殊教育教室的助教缺岗——我告诉他们，我们今天的目标就是像冰球守门员一样，别让球进网。
Two things I learned from calling around to lots of educators over the last few weeks-- school is still a mess. That's the first thing. And number two, the situation in schools right now can only be described using metaphor.
过去几周里，我给很多教育工作者打过电话，学到了两件事——学校依然是一团糟。这是第一点。第二点，目前学校的情况只能用比喻来描述。
We're just going to play for eight hours today and try to keep as few of them from getting by us today. And then we'll recoup tonight and figure out how we can recover for tomorrow.
我们今天只是要坚持八个小时，尽量少让学生溜走。然后晚上休整一下，想想明天怎么补救。
Oh, man. This year-- [CHUCKLES] I'll try not to cry. This year has been hard. [CHUCKLES]
天哪。今年——（轻笑）我尽量不哭。今年太难了。（轻笑）
Amy Gallaway, a teacher in Alaska, says, I thought this year was finally going to be normal. This year is not.
阿拉斯加州的老师Amy Gallaway说，我本以为今年终于能恢复正常了。但并没有。
Like a creaky, creaky bridge that we're trying to get across.
就像我们正努力穿过一座吱吱作响的桥。
The kind of step where you're not going to die, you're going to roll your ankle.
那种不会丧命，但会崴到脚的步伐。
A math teacher in New York City.
一位纽约市的数学老师说道。
And land with your face in a mud puddle and be like, OK, I could have probably navigated that obstacle a little bit differently.
然后脸朝下摔进泥坑里，心想，好吧，我本可以换种方式绕过那个障碍的。
There are not enough teachers. There are not enough school bus drivers. You never know which students will come in person, if at all. Some kids have just disappeared. Enrollment and attendance-- way down.
老师不够用。校车司机也不够用。你永远不知道哪些学生会到校，甚至不知道他们会不会来。有些孩子直接消失了。入学率和出勤率——大幅下降。
The metaphor that I would always use is like, it's as though you are creating a vehicle--
我经常用的比喻是，这就像你在制造一辆车——
You can tell this guy is about to go in really deep, right? English teacher.
听得出来，这位老兄快要深入探讨了，对吧？英语老师。
--while driving it at the same time on a road whose conditions are unclear in terrible weather. That vehicle, by the way, is a school bus. And not only are there 120 kids there, you're also driving from the back of the bus.
——同时还得在天气恶劣、路况不明的道路上开着它。顺便说一下，那辆车是一辆校车。不仅里面有120个孩子，你还是在后座驾驶。
[LAUGHS] That's a metaphor that never ends.
（笑）这真是一个没完没了的比喻。
Yeah. It just compounds.
是啊。负担只会越来越重。
Takeru Nagayoshi, a high school teacher in New Bedford, Massachusetts. Mr. Nagayoshi was Massachusetts teacher of the year for 2020. In 2021, he quit his job-- quit his job, right after being publicly recognized as the very best.
Takeru Nagayoshi，马萨诸塞州新贝德福德的一名高中老师。Nagayoshi先生是2020年马萨诸塞州的年度教师。2021年，他辞职了——就在被公开表彰为最优秀教师之后，他辞职了。
He was at the top of his game, and he walked away, which is a pretty huge reversal. He didn't plan to leave public school teaching. When schools closed and everything went online, Mr. Nagayoshi missed the classroom deeply. He missed all the things you can only do when everyone is in a room together.
他正处于职业生涯的巅峰，却选择离开，这是一个巨大的转折。他没打算离开公立学校的教学岗位。当学校关闭、一切转为线上时，Nagayoshi先生非常怀念教室。他怀念所有只有大家聚在一起才能做的事情。
The group activities, the collaborative mood board work that my kids do, writing on anchor charts, breaking up into small groups, doing practice rounds of public speaking, and Socratic seminars, and peer writing, and taking out your pens so that you can highlight things on your papers, and give that feedback, and offer commentary to each other's research questions. And there are so many opportunities and magic that I think happens in person. And when I think about learning, it's such a social thing.
小组活动、孩子们做的协作情绪板、在挂图上书写、分组、进行公开演讲练习、苏格拉底研讨会、同伴写作、拿出笔在纸上标出重点、给出反馈、对彼此的研究问题发表评论。我认为当面交流会产生很多机会和魔力。当我思考学习时，这真的是一件社交性的事情。
He was used to feeling inspired every day, energized. But even when they were back in person, Mr. Nagayoshi never got that feeling back. His students didn't get to school on time or regularly at all. And they just weren't focused.
他习惯了每天感到振奋和充满活力。但即使恢复线下授课后，Nagayoshi先生再也没找回那种感觉。他的学生们没能准时到校，甚至根本不规律。他们根本无法集中注意力。
They were grieving for people they loved. They were stressed or depressed, juggling lots of responsibilities, or staying up until 4:00 AM playing video games. And they were just out of the habit of doing school. School had been such a regular routine before, for kids, for everyone.
他们为挚爱之人的离世而悲伤。他们感到压力或抑郁，应对着繁重的责任，或者熬夜到凌晨4点玩游戏。他们只是失去了上学的习惯。在这之前，对于孩子们，对于所有人来说，学校曾经是如此规律的日常。
Mr. Nagayoshi told me he started to question if what they were doing was really serving kids. He questioned the most basic things about the way school functions. Like, why did the school day have to be so long? All the rigid routines-- why do they have to learn in class periods? Why every day?
Nagayoshi先生告诉我，他开始怀疑他们所做的一切是否真的服务于孩子。他质疑学校运作方式中最基本的事情。比如，为什么学校的一天必须这么长？所有那些僵化的常规——为什么他们必须在课堂时间内学习？为什么每天都要这样？
Sometimes, I just felt more like a gatekeeper to, like, archaic ways of learning and convening. I don't know, Chana, I just feel like the seal has been broken, and I don't-- and it's hard for me to imagine a world to go back to that magic.
有时，我感觉自己更像是过时学习和集会方式的守门人。我不知道，Chana，我只是觉得封印已经被打破了，我——我很难想象一个能回到那种魔力的世界。
Whoa. What seal has been broken? What does that mean?
哇。什么封印被打破了？那是什么意思？
The-- [SIGHS] what is the seal that has been broken? I think, our relationship to what school is.
那个——（叹气）那个被打破的封印是什么？我想，是我们与学校究竟是什么之间的关系。
It's been two years since school buildings first closed. It's kind of hard to remember how impossible that seemed before it happened-- closing entire school buildings. School seemed like a fact, inevitable. If you're a kid, you go to school five days a week. It's inescapable.
距离校舍首次关闭已经过去两年了。很难回想起在发生之前，关闭整个校舍看起来是多么不可能的事情。学校似乎是一个事实，不可避免。如果你是个孩子，你每周就要上五天学。这是逃不掉的。
But then, it wasn't anymore. Buildings closed for months, more than a year. This happened in lots of different ways across the country. It was worse for some, better for others. But talking with teachers and parents and kids, it's clear that school as they left it March 2020 does not look the same as the school they have now.
但后来，不再是这样了。校舍关闭了数月，甚至超过一年。这种情况在全国各地以各种不同的方式发生。对一些人来说更糟，对另一些人来说则好一些。但与老师、家长和孩子们交谈后，很明显，2020年3月他们离开时的学校，和他们现在拥有的学校已经不一样了。
Classrooms still close. School buses don't come. Or teachers are out sick, or there aren't enough teachers. Some districts have just decided kids don't need to come in on Fridays now. In the state of Missouri, 1/4 of the school districts have now decided to switch to four days of school a week, instead of five.
教室依然会关闭。校车不再来。或者老师生病缺勤，又或者老师不够用。一些学区干脆决定学生现在周五不用来学校了。在密苏里州，四分之一的学区现在决定将学校从一周五天上课改为四天上课。
Some kids stopped coming altogether. School had always been this solid object that now seems much less solid. So many of the people I've been speaking with are questioning the very premise of school, whether it's worth it, whether they need to show up every day, whether they need to be in a classroom.
有些孩子完全停止了上学。学校曾经是一个坚固的实体，但现在看起来远没有那么稳固了。我采访的许多人都在质疑学校的前提本身，质疑它是否值得，质疑他们是否需要每天出现，质疑他们是否需要待在教室里。
It's like everyone involved-- kids, parents, drivers, teachers, superintendents-- all realized at the same time, hey, this treadmill has an off switch. This place is not fact. School is not inevitable. Just listen to the way Mr. Nagayoshi talks about when school was inevitable, back before the pandemic, just a few years ago.
感觉就像所有相关的人——孩子、家长、司机、老师、督学——同时意识到，嘿，这台跑步机是有开关的。这个地方不是既定事实。学校并非不可避免。只要听听Nagayoshi先生谈论大流行之前，也就是几年前学校还是“不可避免”的时候，他是怎么说的。
Sure, it was hard, and things were never perfect, but it was a different time. And I don't know if we can ever get back to that. I think it's a bygone era.
当然，那时候也很难，情况也从不完美，但那是一个不同的时代。我不知道我们是否还能回到过去。我认为那是一个逝去的时代。
Like, the way we've done public school for more than a century?
就像我们进行了一个多世纪的公立学校教育方式？
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
[CHUCKLES] It's gone?
（轻笑）它消失了？
I don't-- I think it is.
我不——我想是的。
Is it? Is school as we've known it over? Today, I want to bring you the stories of two kids who have drifted away from school. And we see what happens when they try to make their way back. Stay with us.
是吗？我们所熟知的学校教育结束了吗？今天，我想给你们讲两个从学校生活中“漂走”的孩子的故事。我们来看看当他们试图回归时会发生什么。请继续收听。
The last couple of months, I've been talking with principals, teachers, parents, and kids about school and what's changed for them two years into a pandemic. And I keep returning to that question-- have schools fundamentally changed? One of the people I've been checking in with, on and off for a while now, is a woman named MJ and her daughter, Neeah.
过去几个月里，我一直在和校长、老师、家长和孩子们谈论学校，以及在大流行两年后，对他们来说发生了什么变化。我不断回到那个问题——学校从根本上改变了吗？我一直在关注的人之一，是一位名叫MJ的女士和她的女儿Neeah。
They're a family of three. MJ is a single parent. Neeah is her youngest, and she has an older daughter, who's grown. They're mixed-race, live in Michigan with a French bulldog. During the pandemic, MJ and Neeah constructed a brand-new and very unusual life with one another. And seeing how much has changed for them, where they ended up after two years of pandemic school, that, maybe more than anyone else I've spoken with, made me feel like, whoa, maybe school as we once knew it truly is over.
她们是三口之家。MJ是一位单亲妈妈。Neeah是她最小的孩子，她还有一个已经成年的大女儿。她们是混血儿，住在密歇根州，养着一只法国斗牛犬。在大流行期间，MJ和Neeah共同构建了一种全新的、非常不寻常的生活。看到她们的生活发生了多大的变化，看到她们在大流行学校生活的两年后处境如何，这让我感觉，也许比我采访过的任何人都更有理由觉得，哇，也许我们曾经熟知的学校真的结束了。
So here's Act One, Big Mother Is Watching. It begins, of course, when the schools closed two years ago.
所以这是第一幕，“大母神”在看着你。故事开始于两年前学校关闭的时候。
Oh, my god. You want to talk about stress? Man.
哦，天哪。你想谈谈压力吗？天哪。
What happened?
发生了什么？
Oh, yeah. It just-- like, what do you do?
哦，是的。这简直就是——你该怎么办？
MJ is a building engineer. She had to go to work. She supervises all the maintenance for buildings she works in around Detroit-- make sure the boilers, lighting, carpentry are all attended to. So at first, she just brought Neeah to work.
MJ是一名建筑工程师。她必须去工作。她负责监督底特律周边她工作区域内所有建筑的维护工作——确保锅炉、照明、木工都得到照看。所以起初，她只是把Neeah带到工作场所。
It was fun, you know what I mean? She didn't get in my way, running around while I'm cleaning up, you know, that area that I have to. So you know, I rode the wave as long as I could.
这很有趣，你懂我的意思吗？她在我不碍事的时候到处跑，我也在清理我必须清理的区域，你知道的。所以，我尽可能久地维持着这种状态。
When her boss made it clear that this was not a long-term arrangement, MJ dropped Neeah with an aunt, then a friend, a babysitter. A neighbor took her for a week.
当她的老板明确表示这不是长久之计后，MJ把Neeah托付给一位阿姨，然后是朋友，还有保姆。邻居带了她一周。
You know, even if it's just a day, OK, exactly how long can they help? You know, throw them money. How much can you afford? Absolutely nothing, but we'll make it work anyway. It's a never-- it's a whole thing. It's exhausting, mentally. Exhausting, OK?
你知道，即使只是一天，好吧，他们到底能帮多久？你知道，给他们点钱。你能负担得起多少？完全负担不起，但我们还是想办法做到了。这从来不是——这是一整套麻烦。这让人精疲力竭，精神上。精疲力竭，懂吗？
And it was months. MJ had a new thought. Neeah was nine years old. She could prepare food herself, get herself dressed. A lot of parents leave kids her age at home alone. But MJ hadn't before, certainly not all day. And she did not want to now, but she had to go to work. She'd be 10 minutes away. She could come home at lunch to check in. Neeah would be on Zoom all day, with a teacher from school.
而且持续了几个月。MJ有了一个新想法。Neeah九岁了。她可以自己准备食物，自己穿衣服。很多家长把这个年纪的孩子单独留在家。但MJ以前没这样做过，肯定没试过整天。她现在也不想这样，但她必须去上班。她离家只有10分钟路程。她可以在午饭时间回家看看。Neeah会整天开着Zoom，跟着学校的老师上网课。
A while back, a friend had recommended security cameras when MJ moved into a new house. MJ ordered a couple. Neeah stayed home alone. MJ left, telling herself, I've got the cameras.
很久以前，MJ搬进新家时，一位朋友推荐了安防摄像头。MJ订购了几个。Neeah独自留在家中。MJ出门时安慰自己说，我有摄像头看着呢。
I could see her in different areas of the house. And I have an alarm system that, if any window or doors opened, it alerts the police and makes a really loud noise. And you know, depending on the area of the house that Neeah's in, she knows what the escape route is and what the emergency plan is.
我可以看到她在房子的不同区域。我还有一个警报系统，如果有任何窗户或门被打开，它会报警并发出很大的声音。而且你知道，根据Neeah所在的房子区域，她知道逃生路线和紧急计划是什么。
You know, it's not something that I wanted to do. I wasn't happy to do it, but I can see my kid. You know, like I said, I got a friend behind me, my neighbor across-- the old lady across the street. Gotta love them, you know?
你知道，这不是我想要做的事。我不乐意这么做，但我能看到我的孩子。你知道，就像我说的，我背后有朋友，我对面——街对面的老太太。你不得不爱她们，你知道吗？
When did you first start watching?
你什么时候开始监视的？
Right away.
立刻。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
No, no, right away. Oh, god, yeah. No. My kid's got to be home by herself? I got to keep my eyes on the camera.
不，不，立刻就开始了。哦，天哪，是的。不。我的孩子必须独自在家？我必须盯着摄像头。
MJ went to work and propped the phone up next to her, all day. If she had to walk, she'd hold the phone in front of her, and she'd watch as Neeah ate breakfast, signed on to school. When MJ couldn't have eyes on the phone, she'd put it in her pocket and put headphones in to listen.
MJ去上班，把手机整天立在身边。如果她必须走动，她会把手机举在面前，看着Neeah吃早餐，登录学校系统。当MJ无法盯着手机看时，她会把它放进兜里，戴上耳机监听。
It's never not been a distraction. I'm always busy, but I have to keep my daughter in my ear, because she's home by herself. You know? So it did interfere with work, you know. It's what I do. Like, I'm on a ladder, trying to change lights, and you know, I've got my phone.
它从来不是一种干扰，因为它一直都在。我总是很忙，但我必须时刻关注着我女儿，因为她独自在家。你知道吗？所以它确实干扰了工作，你知道的。这是我的工作。比如，我站在梯子上试图换灯，而我手里拿着手机。
Like, I'll set it up somewhere. I'll put, like, the phone in my pocket, put my earphones in, so I can at least hear. And if, you know, something sounds awry, like if I hear a bang, I'd pull my phone out, look at the camera real quick. But I'm always listening.
比如，我会把它放在某个地方。我会把手机放进兜里，戴上耳机，这样至少能听到声音。如果，你知道，有什么不对劲，比如我听到砰的一声，我会迅速拿出手机，立刻查看摄像头。但我一直都在听着。
On a ladder?
站在梯子上？
Always listening.
一直在听。
I hate this picture, MJ.
我讨厌这个画面，MJ。
Yeah.
是啊。
You're standing on a ladder, looking at your phone.
你站在梯子上，看着你的手机。
Changing a fluorescent light in a hallway. And yeah, and you'll hear-- now, if you subtract, da-da-da-dah, and like you hear the kids. They're so loud. Yeah, it's bad. It was bad. [CHUCKLES]
在走廊里换日光灯管。是的，你会听到——现在，如果你减去……等等，你可以听到孩子们的声音。他们太吵了。是的，这很糟糕。这真的很糟糕。（轻笑）
MJ watched as much as she could, listened when she couldn't. She was monitoring to keep Neeah safe. But as she watched, MJ started to notice some other things.
MJ尽可能地看着，无法看时就听着。她这样做是为了确保Neeah的安全。但在观察过程中，MJ开始注意到其他一些事情。
Oh. [CHUCKLES] Like, I'm very big on eating in my living room. Like, I don't like to-- I don't like when you eat or drink in my living room. And I've caught her so many times eating and drinking in the living room and setting it next to the laptop. And I don't like my dog on the couch all the time, because he licks his paw, and then licks the couch. And it's just gross. And she'll let him on the couch.
哦。（轻笑）比如，我非常介意在客厅吃东西。我不喜欢在客厅吃喝。我抓到她好多次在客厅吃喝，还把东西放在笔记本电脑旁边。我也不喜欢我的狗总是待在沙发上，因为它会舔爪子，然后舔沙发。这太恶心了。她却总让它待在沙发上。
MJ told me, on the app, you can see everything. And there's a big button right there-- Microphone. If you press it, your voice will blast into the room, sounding sort of like a loud walkie-talkie. I asked--
MJ告诉我，在应用软件上，你可以看到一切。上面有个大按钮——麦克风。如果你按住它，你的声音就会在房间里轰然响起，听起来像个巨大的对讲机。我问——
So did you use it?
那你用过它吗？
Oh, oh, hell yeah. [LAUGHS]
哦，该死，当然用过。（大笑）
Tell me.
告诉我。
I would just hit my Microphone button, and I would catch her watching TV all the time. I'd be like, turn the TV off. What did I say? Getting up, playing with the dog, playing with the cat, back and forth. Like, no, sit your self down, and do your work.
我会按下麦克风按钮，然后经常抓到她在看电视。我会说，把电视关掉。我刚才说什么了？起来，别玩狗，别玩猫，在那来回跑。不，坐好，去做你的功课。
Neeah would get herself a drink, bring it to the living room-- Microphone.
Neeah会给自己拿杯饮料，带到客厅——麦克风启动。
Neeah, you know you're not supposed to have that by the laptop. You need to go put it in the kitchen. Neeah, quit playing with the dog and focus. Turn off the TV. You're not supposed to have the TV on. If you're going to listen to the music, no lyrics. Yeah, it's just constant redirection and correction, over and over.
Neeah，你知道你不应该把那个放在笔记本电脑旁。你需要把它放回厨房。Neeah，别玩狗了，集中注意力。把电视关掉。你不应该开电视。如果你要听音乐，别听带歌词的。是的，这就是不断的纠正和调整，一遍又一遍。
What were the ones that you said the most often?
你最常说的话是什么？
All of 'em.
所有这些。
The app apparently can also record. MJ told me, yeah, you can capture moments on there.
显然，这个应用还可以录音。MJ告诉我，是的，你可以在上面捕捉到瞬间。
Or take pictures.
或者拍照。
Did you do that?
你这么做了吗？
Oh, I've recorded. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
哦，我录过音。哦，是的。哦，是的。
Why?
为什么？
Just so I can go back and show her her behavior. Like, flipping, doing cartwheels, oh, yeah. Mm-hmm, I'll go, oh, yeah. Oh, you're doing cartwheels? OK.
只是为了回头让她看看自己的行为。比如，在那翻跟头，做侧手翻，哦，是的。嗯哼，我会说，哦，你在做侧手翻？好吧。
Did she ever cover up the cameras?
她有没有遮住过摄像头？
She tried to turn one before, yes, so I couldn't watch her watching TV.
她曾经试着转动过其中一个，是的，这样我就不能看她看电视了。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
So she would always definitely feel like I was spying on her. Stop spying on me! [LAUGHS]
所以她绝对会觉得我在监视她。别监视我！（大笑）
It sounds like you were.
听起来你确实在监视。
I mean, was I spying on her, or was I making sure she was OK? You know, tomato, to-ma-to.
我是说，我是在监视她，还是在确保她没事？你知道，西红柿，番茄。
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
Hi, Neeah.
嗨，Neeah。
Hello.
你好。
How are you?
你好吗？
Good.
好。
Neeah told me she jumped the first few times her mom's voice appeared in the room with her. Other times, she says it was just confusing. Her teacher was talking, and her mom was talking. She felt like, wait, who's telling me to do something right now? A version of this happened as Neeah and I talked. MJ was sitting right next to her on the bed, jumping in here and there.
Neeah告诉我，她妈妈的声音头几次在房间里响起时，她吓了一跳。其他时候，她说这只是让人困惑。老师在说话，她妈妈也在说话。她觉得，等一下，到底是谁在指示我做事？当我们交谈时，这种情形也发生了。MJ正坐在床边，时不时地插话。
Is she the same mom through the cameras?
你在摄像头里看到的妈妈和现实中是一样的吗？
Yeah, sometimes. But through the camera, she's more of a helicopter parent. Make sure you get your chores done before I get home, or I'm going to be mad, or you're going to be grounded. And I would always want to watch TV, but she's like, no, turn off the TV, turn off the music, you got to focus. No chewing gum. Make sure you're paying attention.
嗯，有时候。但在摄像头里，她更像一个直升机式家长。确保我在她回家前把家务做完，否则她会生气，或者我会禁足。我总想看电视，但她说，不，关掉电视，关掉音乐，你得集中注意力。别嚼口香糖。确保你在专心。
She said she'd talk to you about your drinks and the dog a lot, too.
她说她也经常跟你说饮料和狗的事。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Are you supposed to drink by the laptop?
你应该在笔记本电脑旁喝东西吗？
No.
不。
Are you supposed to eat by the laptop?
你应该在笔记本电脑旁吃东西吗？
No.
不。
There you go. [CHUCKLES]
就是这样。（轻笑）
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Yeah, it seems more different over the camera, actually, because-- yeah, much more of a micromanager on the cameras than in person.
是的，看起来摄像头那边更不一样，实际上——因为，比起面对面，她在摄像头上更像个事无巨细的微观管理者。
She's micromanaging this conversation.
她在微观管理这段对话。
Yes, she is.
是的，她确实在。
Yeah, I am. Sorry.
是的，我是在。抱歉。
She's doing a good job at it.
她做得很好。
[MJ LAUGHS]
（MJ大笑）
You can tell MJ and Neeah like each other. And even with this setup, the cameras watching Neeah, they started calling it, "the system." It didn't strain their relationship. If anything, the system made them closer.
看得出来MJ和Neeah彼此喜欢。即便有这套“系统”——摄像头监控Neeah，她们开始管它叫“这套系统”。这并没有破坏她们的关系。如果有的话，这套系统反而让她们更亲近了。
When Neeah hadn't heard her mom's voice for a while over the cameras, she'd FaceTime her mom, see what she was up to. She started to learn about her mom's day. She learned her habits. Neeah told me she got to the point where she could anticipate which things would trigger her mom's voice appearing in the room. Like, Neeah would turn on the TV, and as she was doing it--
当Neeah有一段时间没在摄像头里听到妈妈的声音时，她会通过FaceTime找妈妈，看看她在忙什么。她开始了解妈妈的一天。她了解了妈妈的习惯。Neeah告诉我，她甚至能预判哪些事情会触发妈妈的声音在房间里响起。比如，Neeah打开电视，就在她行动的同时——
I'm like, oh, god, I know she's about to come on the camera, tell me to focus, get off the TV.
我就想，哦，天哪，我知道她马上要出现在摄像头里了，告诉我集中精神，别看电视。
[MJ LAUGHS]
（MJ大笑）
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
That's funny.
那很有趣。
You would know ahead of time.
你会提前知道。
Yeah, I would know ahead of time.
是的，我会提前知道。
Did it stop you from doing the thing that she didn't want you to do?
那有没有阻止你做她不想让你做的事？
Um, no. Mm-mm. No. I'm still sassy. I still got some attitude.
嗯，没有。没有。我还是那么调皮。我还是很有态度。
[MJ LAUGHS]
（MJ大笑）
In in-person school in the classroom, this was a problem. Neeah loves to talk. She's a chatty kid, and she'd get in trouble for talking in class, distracting other kids, not keeping her hands to herself. MJ worried about it. She would get calls from school saying Neeah was acting out today. Neeah was suspended.
在学校教室里，这曾是个问题。Neeah喜欢说话。她是个话唠，经常因为在课堂上说话、打扰其他同学、管不住自己的手而惹麻烦。MJ为此担心。她会接到学校的电话，说Neeah今天捣乱了。Neeah被停学了。
Parent-teacher conferences were often a lot of, "Neeah's a great kid, but she has a hard time focusing." But now, the space between home and school had collapsed. Instead of hearing about Neeah second-hand, MJ was watching. And she says it was kind of amazing. Neeah was curious. She was hard-working.
家长会通常都是，“Neeah是个好孩子，但很难集中注意力。”但现在，家庭和学校之间的空间崩塌了。MJ不是通过二手消息了解Neeah，而是亲自看着。她说这简直太神奇了。Neeah很好奇。她很努力。
She would ask questions. Like, if she didn't know, she'd raise her hand, because you'd see her on camera-- raise her hand, waiting patiently and quietly. Whereas Neeah, she usually-- she interrupts. Let's just be real.
她会提问。比如，如果她不懂，她会举手，因为你可以看到她出现在镜头里——举起手，耐心地安静等待。而通常，Neeah总是打断别人。让我们面对现实吧。
Not saying she never interrupted, but like, I just-- she was raising her hand, waiting patiently, asked questions, gave the right answer. And it's like, I don't ever get to see that. You know what I mean? I don't get to hear the good stuff all the time.
我不是说她从不打断，但是——她是在举手，耐心地等待，问问题，给出正确的答案。这让我感觉，我以前从来没看到过这些。你懂我的意思吗？我不能总是听到关于她的好消息。
That's really kind of special that you got to see her that way.
看到她那一面真的很特别。
Yeah.
是的。
Like, to see her strengths and what she's capable of.
比如，看到她的优点和她的能力。
Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. And her weaknesses, you know. I see the distraction. She is easily distracted. You know, it is hard, and just-- well, it's difficult for her to stay focused, you know? But when she gets into her groove, you know, she stays in it. And she just does amazing things. Yeah.
是的。是的。绝对。还有她的缺点，你知道的。我看到了她的注意力分散。她很容易分心。你知道，这很困难，只是——嗯，她确实很难集中注意力，你知道吗？但当她进入状态时，你知道，她会保持住。她能做出惊人的事情。是的。
I'm glad I got to see this side of my kid that they haven't seen, that I haven't seen. And it's like, this is who she is. I've had that moment, like wow, this is who my kid is.
我很高兴我看到了孩子这一面，老师没看到，我也没看到。感觉就像，这就是她。我有过那种时刻，哇，这就是我的孩子。
I'd never heard of someone doing this-- MJ's system, using security cameras in your house to monitor kids doing remote school, while you have to go to work. It seemed extreme to me, but then I considered all the other arrangements and half-solutions I've heard parents devising to replace what school provided-- a free, dependable place to drop your kids.
我从没听说过有人这样做——MJ的这套系统，用家里的安防摄像头监控远程学习的孩子，而自己不得不去工作。这对我来说似乎很极端，但随后我考虑了其他家长为了替代学校提供的免费、可靠的孩子看管地所采取的所有其他方案和权宜之计。
Parents who brought kids to their jobs at restaurants planted them at a table in the corner, while they worked their shift and hoped nobody in management asked, whose kid is that? Moms who put their children in empty hotel rooms to do remote school while they cleaned the other rooms down the hall. Parents who cut back on their hours or quit their jobs, took night shifts, so they could stay up all day with their kids doing Zoom school.
把孩子带到餐厅工作、让他们坐在角落桌边的父母；妈妈们把孩子放在空酒店房间里远程学习，而自己在走廊的房间打扫卫生。缩减工时或辞职，改上夜班，以便白天能陪孩子上Zoom网课的父母。
Families that moved their entire lives to new cities that were cheaper or closer to a grandma who could look after the kids. MJ had a system that did not require her to depend on anyone else. The system was never late, or stuck in traffic, or sick, or too tired. It's kind of ingenious. School was not reliable. The system was entirely within her control.
为了节省开支或离能照顾孩子的祖母更近一点，举家搬到新城市的家庭。MJ拥有一个不需要依赖任何人的系统。这个系统从不迟到、不堵车、不生病、也不疲劳。这很有创造力。学校并不可靠。这套系统完全在她的掌控之中。
Did you know other people who were doing this?
你认识其他这样做的人吗？
No. I mean, if other moms are out there not wanting to say nothing, I get it. But, whew, there's not that panic of what so many other parents had to face that didn't have a system. I feel like I should do like an infomercial or something, you know-- (LAUGHING) for the system of security cameras and things like that.
没有。我的意思是，如果其他妈妈也在这样做但不愿提起，我明白。但是，呼，总比那些没有系统、面临恐慌的家长好多了。我觉得我应该做个广告什么的，你知道——（大笑）关于这套安防摄像头系统。
Yeah.
是啊。
I made it work. [LAUGHS] I made it work.
我想办法做到了。（大笑）我想办法做到了。
And then, schools reopened. After 11 months of constant contact with her mom, zero separation, Neeah went back to a school building.
后来，学校重新开放了。在与妈妈保持了11个月的密切联系、零分离之后，Neeah回到了校舍。
I had butterflies the entire time I was there. I'm like, oh, my god. What if I do something wrong? What if I get suspended today? And like, what if I don't make it through fourth grade?
我在那里的时候一直很紧张。我就想，哦，我的天哪。如果我做错了什么怎么办？如果我今天被停学了怎么办？如果我四年级没读完怎么办？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Just a whole day of butterflies, and--
整天都在紧张，而且——
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, in the snap of a finger, I'm like, oh, crap. And my mom's not going to be here to be-- like, be here to watch over me, tell me to focus. Like, how am I going to do this? How am I going to do that without her telling me what to do? And that's when I started getting these panic attacks. Like--
是的，转眼之间，我就想，噢糟了。我妈妈不会在这里了——在这里看着我，告诉我集中精神。我该怎么做？没有她告诉我该怎么做，我该怎么做那些事情？那时我就开始有这些恐慌症了。就像——
You started getting panic attacks when you went back to school?
你回到学校时就开始有恐慌症了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I'm sorry to hear that.
听到这个我很遗憾。
Mm-hmm. One of them was really bad, because I was in a panic attack for about 10, 15 minutes, because someone made me mad, really mad, kind of to the point where I started to cry a little bit. And then, I asked the substitute teacher if I can go to the bathroom. And then that's when it happened.
嗯哼。其中一次真的很严重，因为我恐慌发作了大约10、15分钟，因为有人让我生气了，真的很生气，甚至到了我开始哭的地步。然后，我问代课老师我能不能去洗手间。就在那时发生了。
Like, I completely stopped. My heart stopped. My hands were shaking completely. I couldn't even talk. And then, thank god, this teacher, Ms. Murf let me sit in her room for a little bit, cool down, and go back to my room.
我就完全停下来了。我的心跳停止了。我的手在颤抖，完全无法控制。我甚至说不出话。然后，谢天谢地，这位老师，Murf女士让我坐在她的办公室里待了一会儿，冷静一下，然后又回到了教室。
You know, when you send a preschooler to their first day of school, that first big separation? And it's so hard, but you can never really know exactly what it's like for the kid, because they're so little. They can't really articulate it. But here is a fourth-grader who can.
你知道，当你送一个学龄前儿童去上第一天学，那种第一次重大分离？那真的很难，但你永远无法准确知道这对孩子来说意味着什么，因为他们太小了。他们无法准确表达。但这里有一个能表达的四年级学生。
Neeah says she missed knowing where her mom was. She missed her voice in the room. When things happened at school, when a kid said something mean, or she didn't understand the teacher, she wanted her mom there to take care of it, to protect her.
Neeah说她想念那种知道妈妈在哪里的感觉。她想念房间里妈妈的声音。当学校里发生事情时，当有孩子说刻薄的话，或者她听不懂老师讲课时，她希望妈妈在那里照看她，保护她。
Like, how I said she was talking a lot on the cameras?
就像我说她在摄像头里经常说话一样？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
My life would be easier if she could see every move, everything that would happen, and know beforehand, and then contact somebody right away. But the world is not like that, so--
如果妈妈能看到每一个动作、每一个发生的事情、提前知道，然后立刻联系某人，我的生活会更容易。但世界不是那样的，所以——
Yeah. Yeah, that's sort of part of growing up, I think.
是的。是的，我想那是成长的一部分。
Mm-hmm. It would still be nice to hear her say, don't do this, don't do that, like it is in movies.
嗯哼。如果能听到她说，别做这个，别做那个，就像电影里那样，还是挺好的。
Like, you mean a narrator in a movie?
你是说电影里的旁白？
Yeah. Yeah, like my mom would be the narrator of my head, and she'd tell me, make sure you ask questions, get the answers right, don't get distracted.
是的。是的，就像我妈妈是我的大脑旁白，她会告诉我，一定要问问题，把答案答对，别分心。
It's kind of what you hope happens with your kid, that your voice gets in their head and helps guide them through difficult stuff, but you know, a metaphorical voice in the head that eventually it becomes their own voice as they develop into their own people. Neeah had come to rely on a literal voice and just her mom's presence.
这正是你希望在孩子身上发生的事情，他们的声音进入孩子的脑海，帮助引导他们度过困难的事情，但你知道，脑海中的隐喻声音，最终会随着他们成长为独立的个体，变成他们自己的声音。Neeah已经开始依赖真实的声音和她妈妈的存在。
Neeah heard from her mom so much during the day, through the cameras or on FaceTime, she missed knowing what her mom was up to at any given moment. She says it's actually what she missed most-- tracking her mom's day in parallel with her school day. It felt scary to lose that.
Neeah白天经常通过摄像头或FaceTime听到妈妈的声音，她想念那种能时刻知道妈妈在干什么的感觉。她说这实际上是她最想念的事情——在自己的学校生活同时追踪妈妈的一天。失去这种联系让人感到害怕。
I wish I could see and watch whatever she's doing. I'd want to see her, how hard she's working, or when people just don't give her anything to do. And then, just see what she eats for lunch-- if she eats lunch or breakfast-- because she doesn't really eat lunch or breakfast, because she doesn't get enough time to eat breakfast.
我真希望我能看到并观察她正在做什么。我想看看她，她工作有多努力，或者当别人不给她安排任务时她在做什么。然后，看看她午饭吃什么——如果不吃午饭或早饭的话——因为她没有足够的时间吃早饭。
You worry about her not eating?
你担心她没吃东西吗？
I do, because breakfast and lunch are probably the most important meals of the day.
我担心，因为早饭和午饭可能是最重要的两餐。
So if you could choose, you would like to have her watching you all the time and you watching her all the time?
所以如果让你选择，你希望她一直看着你，你也一直看着她？
Yeah.
是的。
MJ, Neeah's mother, does not want this. What MJ wanted was to go back to how things were, where she'd drop Neeah at school and drive away, back to the time when school assumed responsibility for her child's safety and well-being. But once Neeah was back in school, MJ kept waiting for that feeling, the separation between parent life and work life, to set in.
Neeah的妈妈MJ并不想这样。MJ想要的是回到过去的状态，她会把Neeah送到学校然后开车离开，回到那个学校承担孩子安全和福利责任的时代。但在Neeah回到学校后，MJ一直在等待那种家长生活和工作生活分离的感觉产生。
But it didn't. It felt different. First of all, Neeah was at a different school. Right before the pandemic, MJ bought a house, not far, but in a different school district. So that took getting used to, but there were other things.
但这没有发生。感觉不同了。首先，Neeah在一所不同的学校。在大流行之前，MJ买了房子，离得不远，但在另一个学区。所以这需要时间适应，但还有其他事情。
Neeah bonded with her new teacher. And then suddenly, there was a substitute teacher, then another sub. Students got COVID. Teachers got COVID. Whole classrooms closed. Neeah's favorite teacher-- the art teacher, Ms. Gonzales-- quit. The next art teacher-- she quit, too. One day, MJ went to drop Neeah off at the bus stop.
Neeah和她的新老师建立了联系。然后突然之间，来了一位代课老师，然后又换了一位。学生得了新冠。老师得了新冠。整个教室关闭。Neeah最喜欢的老师——艺术老师Gonzales女士——辞职了。下一位艺术老师——也辞职了。有一天，MJ去接送Neeah上校车。
It just didn't come. It didn't come one morning. The bus never came one morning. There was issues with subs. And I mean, I don't really know what their issues are, but it was a sub on both days. And you know, I'm at work.
它就是没来。有一天早上没来。校车有一天早上没来。代课老师有问题。我的意思是，我不知道他们有什么问题，但那两天是代课老师。而且你知道，我在工作。
When she went to pick Neeah up after school--
当她放学后去接Neeah时——
At the end of the day, I'm at the bus stop waiting for the bus. The bus came. She didn't get off the bus. I panicked.
一天结束时，我在校车站等校车。校车来了。她没下车。我慌了。
What went through your head when she didn't get off the bus?
当她没下车时，你脑子里闪过了什么？
Just, it's instant, like, oh, my god-- just afraid. Like, I wouldn't even know where to begin to look for my daughter in the city. God forbid.
就是瞬间，比如，哦，我的天——只是恐惧。比如，我甚至不知道从哪里开始在这个城市寻找我的女儿。天哪，千万别发生那种事。
The old way of doing school, the pre-pandemic way, felt different. MJ hated not knowing where Neeah was. She hated not seeing what was happening in the school building. The separation felt natural before, but now it felt agonizing.
旧的教学方式，大流行之前的方式，感觉不同了。MJ讨厌不知道Neeah在哪里。她讨厌看不到校舍里发生的事情。以前分离感觉很自然，但现在感觉很痛苦。
Neeah would say there were fights at school. MJ wished she could see what happened. There was an incident with Neeah, another kid, and a marker. Another time, Neeah came home saying a boy touched her butt, and MJ was irate that it happened, but also that she didn't know it was happening, that the school hadn't called right away.
Neeah会说学校有打架事件。MJ希望她能看到发生了什么。Neeah和一个孩子以及一支记号笔发生了纠纷。另一次，Neeah回家说有个男孩摸了她的屁股，MJ对发生这种事感到暴怒，但更愤怒的是她竟然不知道，学校没有第一时间通知她。
Whatever happens, happens. And then when they have all the information, then they want to call you. I want to know right away. Constant communication-- I don't care if you have to interrupt my day at work. If something is going on with my child, I need to know about it. Like, I'm in the loop.
发生什么就发生了。当他们掌握了所有信息，他们才想给你打电话。我想立刻知道。不断的沟通——我不在乎你是否必须打断我的工作。如果我的孩子发生了什么事，我需要知道。就像，我在关注中。
Yeah. Part of what seems like might be happening is that you had this year where you were deeply involved in every single thing Neeah did, and you watched. You were literally watching her.
是的。看起来可能发生的一部分原因是，你有一年的时间深度参与了Neeah做的每一件事，而且你在看。你确实在看着她。
Everything.
每一件事。
Yeah. And now, you have to trust this school and all these people in the school--
是的。而现在，你必须信任这所学校和学校里的所有人——
That seems very incompetent, mm-hmm.
那看起来非常无能，嗯哼。
--and a school system to do what you were doing.
——以及一个学校系统来做你当时做的事情。
Yeah. You know, it's very hard for my daughter to be in a new district, me to not have control, to not see her, but to not be in the loop of things. Yes, that is very hard. You know what I mean? It's like, oh, my god-- it's so frustrating. Since you are, like, at the end of my workday, I am about to order my lunch, so if you could just give me one second.
是的。你知道，我女儿在一个新学区，我没有控制权，我看不到她，无法掌握情况，这对她来说非常难。是的，这非常难。你懂我的意思吗？感觉就像，噢，我的天——这太令人沮丧了。既然你，也就是在我工作日结束的时候，我正准备点午餐，所以如果你能给我一秒钟的话。
No problem.
没问题。
I'm so sorry.
我很抱歉。
Please-- no, eat. Eat.
请——不，吃吧。吃吧。
But I am starving.
但我饿坏了。
MJ was grasping for a plan, calling the school repeatedly for help, not eating breakfast, as her daughter suspected.
MJ一直在寻找计划，反复打电话给学校寻求帮助，没吃早饭，正如她女儿猜测的那样。
[SIGHS] I feel like I just want to pull her, regardless, before I even have a plan. You know? I'm trying to mentally come up with a plan, while trying to work full-time and doing all this over-time. I'm trying, but it's like, oh, god, that's her school calling me right now.
（叹气）我觉得我还是想把她接走，不管怎样，甚至在我有计划之前。你知道吗？我正试图在脑子里想出个计划，同时还要做全职工作，做所有这些加班。我在努力，但感觉就像，哦，天哪，那是她学校现在正给我打电话。
Oh, go ahead. Call me back.
哦，你忙你的。回头再打给我。
OK, give me just--
好的，给我一点——
OK. Take your time.
好的。慢慢来。
Give me one moment. OK. Hello?
给我一会时间。好的。喂？
Hey, MJ. It's Chana.
嘿，MJ。是Chana。
Hey, how are you?
嘿，你好吗？
Good. How have you been?
好。你最近怎么样？
No, I've been good. I've been real good.
不，我很好。我真的很好。
This relaxed, breezy person is a mother who has her daughter back at home. In January, MJ pulled Neeah from school. The district is offering a virtual option, so Neeah is back online.
这个放松、悠闲的人是一位让女儿回到身边的母亲。一月份，MJ让Neeah退学了。学区提供了虚拟选项，所以Neeah又回到了网上学习。
Yeah. No, I'm not returning her [INAUDIBLE] with all the fifth graders-- all of fifth grade.
是啊。不，我没有让她回到那些五年级学生中间——所有五年级。
So you're just kind of like, we're going to sit this whole thing out?
所以你只是觉得，我们要避开这一切？
Yeah, um--
是啊，嗯——
For how long?
多久？
That's what I don't know.
那正是我不知道的。
MJ told me, if the school situation did not improve, she'd consider remote school for the rest of Neeah's education. This is when I began to wonder if school, as we've known it, might be over. It's not only that MJ was questioning Neeah's school in all these new ways, it's that now, she could imagine an alternative. When something ever-present and unquestioned in your life disappears for a year, you learn it's not the only way to do things. And there's no unknowing that.
MJ告诉我，如果学校的情况没有改善，她会考虑Neeah余下的教育都采取远程教育。这时我开始怀疑，我们所熟知的学校教育是否可能已经结束了。这不仅仅是因为MJ以各种新方式质疑Neeah的学校，而是现在，她可以想象出一种替代方案。当生活中一直存在且毫无疑问的事物消失一年后，你会意识到这不是唯一的做事方式。而且这种认知是无法抹去的。
Instead of returning to school, MJ and Neeah returned to the system. It was exactly the same, except for the school part. Neeah is in virtual school again, but this time it's not run by her public school. Neeah's school district did what an increasing number of public districts are now doing. They subcontracted a private company to provide an online remote-school option.
MJ和Neeah没有回到学校，而是回到了“系统”。除了学校部分，其他一切都一样。Neeah又回到了虚拟学校，但这不再是由她的公立学校运营。Neeah的学区做了越来越多的公立学区现在正在做的事情。他们外包给一家私营公司来提供在线远程教学选项。
The company provides an online platform and the curriculum. Neeah can go on, get all her lessons all by herself. She's not on Zoom. There's no teacher giving live instruction, and there's no classmates. She does everything alone, independently.
这家公司提供在线平台和课程。Neeah可以自己上线，独自获取所有课程。她没开Zoom。没有老师进行实时授课，也没有同学。她一切都独自完成。
I just wake up in the morning. I get my hair done, get my teeth brushed, get dressed. I can do any subject I like, if I wanted to-- English, learning arts, math, PE, art.
我早上起床。整理头发，刷牙，穿衣服。我可以做任何我想做的学科——英语、学习艺术、数学、体育、美术。
Do you miss having teachers?
你怀念老师吗？
No.
不。
[MJ LAUGHS]
（MJ大笑）
I don't.
我不怀念。
What if you don't understand the instructions?
如果你看不懂说明书怎么办？
I can message the teacher, 'cause it gives me a little email box.
我可以给老师发信息，因为它给了我一个小邮件框。
She can email a teacher, but she rarely does. Neeah told me she likes that she can pace herself. She structures her own day. Sometimes, she starts at 8:00 AM, sometimes 9:00. Works for a couple hours, then has lunch. Watches Netflix, and just keeps going until she's done.
她可以发邮件给老师，但她很少这样做。Neeah告诉我，她喜欢自己掌控进度。她安排自己的一天。有时她早上8点开始，有时9点。工作几个小时，然后吃午饭。看Netflix，一直做到结束。
I can just-- like, if it takes me all day, I'll do it all day.
我可以——比如，如果它花掉我一整天，我就花一整天做。
I would like for it to be done before I get home, though, you know?
但我希望它在我回家前完成，你知道吧？
I always get it done.
我总是能完成。
She shouldn't be in school while I'm getting home from work. But--
她不应该在我下班回家时还在上学。但是——
I'm usually done at, like, 12:00.
我通常在12点左右做完。
Will you go a whole day without talking to anybody else?
你会整天不跟任何人说话吗？
Yeah.
会。
So you can get yourself up at 7:00 in the morning, do your work yourself, take your break, watch TV, go back to doing your work, finish your schoolwork, and get to the end of the day without talking to anybody?
所以你可以早上7点起床，自己做功课，休息，看电视，回去做功课，完成学业，直到一天结束都不跟任何人说话？
Um, no. 'Cause every time I wake up in the morning, I'm like, I'm going to call Mom, make sure she's OK, make sure she got to work safely.
嗯，不会。因为每次早上起床，我都想，我要给妈妈打个电话，确保她没事，确保她安全到达工作地点。
She calls me, literally, every day, every morning.
她确实，字面意义上，每天、每天早上都给我打电话。
Is this school? It lacks every element I might have said defines what school is. She doesn't go to a building. There's no teaching, no schedule, no classmates. That's the part I couldn't get over. No kids. The only person Neeah talks to all day is her mom.
这是学校吗？它缺乏我可能认为定义学校的所有要素。她不去建筑，没有教学，没有课程表，没有同学。那是我无法克服的部分。没有孩子。Neeah整天说话的唯一对象就是她妈妈。
That part worries MJ, that Neeah's missing everything about school that mattered most to MJ as a kid. MJ says school's where I figured out who I was. It's where I learned I'm not the prettiest girl, but the fastest on field day. It's where she learned when to fight, how to apologize.
MJ担心这一部分，担心Neeah错过了作为孩子时对MJ最重要的一切。MJ说学校是我发现自我身份的地方。在那里我学会了我不是最漂亮的女孩，但我是运动会上跑得最快的。在那里她学会了何时反击，如何道歉。
It's where she made her best friends, lifelong friendships, she says, of 26-plus years. She's worried Neeah is missing all of that. But Neeah sounds pretty settled, like she'd finally arrived.
在那里她交到了最好的朋友，她说那是26年以上的终身友谊。她担心Neeah错过了这一切。但Neeah听起来很满足，好像她终于到达了目的地。
Total peace and quiet is my kind of thing.
绝对的平静和安静是我喜欢的东西。
When Neeah takes a break or finishes her online work, she sits on the couch at home, and she watches her favorite show on Netflix-- Alexa and Katie. It's a wholesome sitcom about two best friends. One gets cancer, but survives. And now, they're heading to high school for the first time, choosing their first-day-of-school outfits. Will they have the same lunch period?
当Neeah休息或完成在线工作时，她坐在家里的沙发上，观看她最喜欢的Netflix剧集——《亚历克萨与凯蒂》。这是一部关于两个好朋友的健康情景喜剧。一个患了癌症，但活了下来。现在，她们第一次进入高中，挑选开学第一天的行头。她们会有同样的午餐时间吗？
Everyone, get out your school schedules. One, two, three.
所有人，拿出你们的学校时间表。一，二，三。
I'm Alexa, and this is my best friend, Katie. We're about to start high school.
我是亚历克萨，这是我最好的朋友凯蒂。我们马上要开始上高中了。
Oh, my gosh. That's in three days.
天哪。那还有三天。
This is what Neeah's watching from her dystopian cyber school surveillance state. She's watching school. When Takeru Nagayoshi, the Teacher of the Year, who we heard from at the beginning of this show, told me pre-pandemic school was a bygone era, I think this is what that looks like-- Neeah watching school alone in her home, with cameras watching her.
这就是Neeah在她的反乌托邦网络学校监控状态下观看的内容。她在看“学校”。当年度教师Takeru Nagayoshi在节目开头对我说大流行前的学校是一个逝去的时代时，我想这就是它的样子——Neeah独自在家里看着学校，同时摄像头看着她。
That's where this story was going to end. But last week, as I was putting it together, I got one more message from MJ. She said she learned Neeah had not been submitting assignments in her online school. Turns out a teacher-less outsourced program with no actual person-to-person interaction did not work. Or at least, it didn't work for Neeah.
故事本该到此结束。但上周，在我整理它时，我收到了MJ的一条信息。她说她得知Neeah没有在网校提交作业。事实证明，没有实际人与人互动的教师外包项目根本没用。或者至少，对Neeah没用。
MJ was deeply deflated. Her system had failed, and the school system had failed, too. She told me she'd decided to send Neeah back to school in person, for now. That is, until she figures out what's next.
MJ感到非常泄气。她的系统失败了，学校系统也失败了。她告诉我，她决定让Neeah先回到学校上课。至少，直到她想出下一步怎么办。
Coming up, a kid who disappeared from school a year and a half ago shows up again and tries to just blend in. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一个一年半前从学校消失的孩子再次出现，并试图融入其中。那是芝加哥公共广播电台在我们的节目继续时带来的内容。
It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. At the show this year, we've been talking a lot about a feeling we've all noticed around us-- a feeling of unraveling. We're doing a couple of episodes about people who are facing things that feel like they're coming apart in front of them. Like, we did a show a couple of weeks ago about cities and towns becoming unlivable with climate change.
这是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。今年在节目中，我们一直在谈论一种我们在周围都注意到的感觉——一种解体的感觉。我们正在制作几集关于人们面对那些感觉正在他们面前分崩离析的事物的节目。就像几周前我们做了一期关于气候变化让城镇变得不适合居住的节目。
This episode is also about that feeling, a slow-moving unraveling in schools. We are now in the third consecutive school year disrupted by COVID-- disruptions that have at times undone even the most basic foundational part of what school is, like the idea that kids go to school every day. Attendance is down. Enrollment is down.
这一集也是关于那种感觉，学校里缓慢进行的解体。我们现在处于因新冠疫情而中断的连续第三个学年——这些中断有时甚至撤销了学校最基本、最基础的部分，比如孩子们每天上学的理念。出勤率下降了。入学率下降了。
I remember back when schools first closed two years ago, there were kids who just disappeared. I saw a report in the fall of 2020 that estimated three million kids were out of touch with school. A principal in Los Angeles, Vanessa Garza, told me about one of them-- a student they completely lost track of when schools closed in March 2020. And then a month into this school year, I was talking with Principal Garza on the phone, and she says, oh, that girl who disappeared back in spring 2020--
我记得两年前学校刚关闭时，有些孩子直接消失了。我在2020年秋天看到一份报告估计有300万孩子与学校失去联系。洛杉矶的一位校长Vanessa Garza告诉了我其中一个——一个在2020年3月学校关闭时完全失去踪迹的学生。而在这一学年开始一个月后，我和Garza校长通了电话，她说，哦，那个2020年春天消失的女孩——
Literally, yesterday, that student and her family just re-enrolled with us.
就在昨天，那个学生和她的家人重新向我们注册了。
Just yesterday?
就在昨天？
Exactly. You know, I'd like to come back. We're like, great. Let's get a copy of your records. Where were you? What school were you at, so I can request them? And they're like, I didn't go to school. So in the time that the pandemic started and shut down our schools, March 13, 2020, till now, that student hasn't been in school.
确切地说。你知道，我很高兴回来。我们说，太好了。让我们拿一份你的记录。你在哪儿？你在哪所学校，我好去调取？他们说，我没上学。所以从大流行开始并关闭我们学校的2020年3月13日到现在，那个学生一直没上学。
She never finished sixth grade, missed all of seventh grade. And now here she was, a month into her eighth-grade school year, ready to return. This kid-- I'm going to call her Maricela. That's not her real name.
她从未读完六年级，错过了整个七年级。而现在她来了，在八年级开学一个月后，准备回来了。这个孩子——我叫她Maricela。那不是她的真名。
Her mom told me I could meet her at school for one of her first days back, which I really wanted to, because I'd always wanted to know, what were kids who were not in school doing all that time? Literally, like, what was she doing with her time? What were her days like for the last year and a half? And what would it be like to come back to school?
她妈妈告诉我，我可以在她回校的头几天里在学校见她，我真的很想，因为我一直想知道，那些不上学的孩子在那段时间里都在干什么？字面意思，她用时间干了什么？过去一年半她的日子是怎么过的？回到学校会是什么样子？
So that is Act Two, The Case of the Vanishing Sixth Grader.
所以这是第二幕，消失的六年级学生案。
Good morning.
早上好。
Hi. Good morning.
嗨。早上好。
I'm waiting in the hallway with Principal Vanessa Garza at the Girls' Athletic Leadership School, GALS. It's a charter school in Los Angeles, one of those California schools where lots of stuff happens outside next to palm trees. Almost all the students are Latina, some from transnational families that will travel back and forth to family in Mexico or Central America for holidays.
我正和洛杉矶女子领导力学校（GALS）的校长Vanessa Garza在走廊里等待。这是一所位于洛杉矶的特许学校，是那种加州学校之一，很多活动都在棕榈树旁边的室外进行。几乎所有的学生都是拉美裔，有些来自在墨西哥或中美洲有家庭、假期会往返的跨国家庭。
Sometimes, students who have just moved to LA from those places show up at GALS. But a kid who's been missing for 18 months-- that is not common. Principal Vanessa Garza is eagerly scanning the hallway, looking for Maricela. Is she actually going to show?
有时，刚从那些地方搬到洛杉矶的学生会出现在GALS。但是一个失踪了18个月的孩子——那并不常见。Vanessa Garza校长正热切地扫描着走廊，寻找Maricela。她真的会来吗？
Fingers crossed. It's almost 7:30 right now. [LAUGHS]
祈祷。现在快7点半了。（大笑）
We turned to see another staff member hustling down the hall toward us, silently waving her arms and mouthing, she's here!
我们转头看到另一名工作人员正匆忙地向我们走来，默默挥动手臂，口型说着，她来了！
She's here? Yay! All right.
她来了？耶！好的。
The second Maricela walked into the building, I felt like, OK, I'm finally going to get my answer. Where has she been? What happened? And what's it like to be back here?
Maricela走进大楼的那一刻，我感觉，好吧，我终于要得到答案了。她去哪了？发生了什么？回到这里是什么感觉？
But she's kind of like a famous person right now, so I had to wait my turn. She enters the hallway to the school, and immediately gets sort of trapped between the bathroom, the main office, and her principal, who can barely contain her excitement.
但她现在有点像个名人了，所以我必须排队等候。她进入通往学校的走廊，立刻被困在洗手间、教务办公室和几乎无法抑制兴奋的校长之间。
Good morning! How are you? Did you get a chance to get breakfast?
早上好！你好吗？有机会吃早饭了吗？
Maricela's got long, straight, black hair parted in the middle, gray leggings, and a red JanSport backpack. She's barely audible, arms at her chest. She looks like she'd very much like to make herself smaller, less visible, but her overeager host keeps offering her things.
Maricela留着中分的长直黑发，穿着灰色紧身裤，背着一个红色的JanSport背包。她几乎听不见声音，双臂抱在胸前。她看起来很想让自己变得更小、更不显眼，但她那位过于热情的接待者一直在给她东西。
Do you want to grab something that you can save for later? Because it's just coffee cake. You're good? OK. You're in Ms. Elaina's wellness team, right? All right, so let's walk over there and check in with Ms. Elaina. And then, I'll get you a fresh mask, too. It looks like that one is well-loved, right? [CHUCKLES]
想拿点可以留着以后吃的东西吗？因为只是咖啡蛋糕。你饱了吗？好的。你在Elaina女士的健康小组对吧？好的，那我们走过去和Elaina女士报到一下。然后，我会给你一个新口罩，看起来那个已经很旧了，对吧？（轻笑）
Maricela does not laugh or react at all. The wellness team-- that's the school's version of homeroom. It's down the hall and around the corner. Outside the classroom is Ms. Elaina, a tiny blonde teacher from Wisconsin. Hi, she says. How are you doing? Inaudible word.
Maricela没有笑，也没有任何反应。健康小组——那是学校版本的班会课。它在走廊的尽头转弯处。教室外是Elaina女士，一位来自威斯康星州的娇小金发老师。嗨，她说。你怎么样？（听不清的词）
Ms. Elaina guides Maricela into the classroom, saying, did you hear the thunderstorm last night? Silent nod. It was wild, right? Nothing. It's early still. There are only a couple of kids in the classroom.
Elaina女士引导Maricela走进教室，说，昨晚听到雷雨了吗？默默点头。很狂野，对吧？什么反应都没有。还很早。教室里只有几个孩子。
Maricela sits, and Ms. Elaina pulls up right next to her to quietly explain what the homeroom class will be going over today, before first period starts. She says, just yesterday, they began preparing all the eighth-graders for high school applications.
Maricela坐下，Elaina女士紧挨着她坐下，安静地解释第一节课开始前今天要过什么内容。她说，就在昨天，他们开始为所有八年级学生准备高中申请。
Um, have you been able to talk with your mom at all about the high schools that may be good for you, like ones that are nearby, or ones that you're interested in going to?
嗯，你有没有和你妈妈谈过哪些高中可能适合你，比如附近的学校，或者你感兴趣的学校？
No, not yet.
没有，还没。
So that would be-- hey, morning.
所以那会是——嘿，早上好。
Kids are trickling in. Maricela's body is slowly forming into a U-shape around the desk. Like, maybe she thinks she'll blend in, and no one will notice there's anything here but a desk. Meanwhile, Ms. Elaina opens up a laptop to show Maricela some info on her options for high school.
孩子们正陆陆续续进来。Maricela的身体正慢慢变成一个U形包围着桌子。就好像，也许她认为这样她就能融入其中，没人会注意到除了桌子以外还有什么东西存在。同时，Elaina女士打开笔记本电脑向Maricela展示一些关于高中选择的信息。
A religious school, a charter school, an LAUSD neighborhood school, meaning, like, one of the LAUSD schools where you live right around.
宗教学校，特许学校，洛杉矶联合学区（LAUSD）社区学校，意味着，比如，你家附近的那种洛杉矶联合学区的学校。
Nobody acknowledges how strange it is that they're talking about high school, given Maricela has missed most of middle school so far. The last time she was here, she was 11 years old. She's now 13. Sixth to eighth grade-- a lot happens between sixth and eighth grade.
没人承认谈论高中有多奇怪，鉴于Maricela到目前为止已经错过了大部分初中课程。她上次来这里时，她才11岁。她现在13岁。六年级到八年级——六年级和八年级之间发生了太多事情。
I keep thinking of the blip, that thing from The Avengers where Thanos snaps his fingers? It's like Maricela blipped middle school. When she left sixth grade, they were covering early Roman civilization. She missed the entire fall of the Roman Empire-- that was seventh grade-- medieval Europe, too, and the Renaissance.
我一直想到那个“闪现”，《复仇者联盟》里灭霸打响指的那件事？Maricela就像把初中闪现掉了。她离开六年级时，他们正在讲早期罗马文明。她错过了罗马帝国的整个衰落——那是七年级的事——还有中世纪欧洲，文艺复兴也是。
She also missed geometry, photosynthesis, chemistry. She missed a year and a half of reading and writing. And then, blip, eighth grade. Time to move on. Time to fill out a Google form on the transition to high school.
她还错过了几何、光合作用、化学。她错过了一年半的阅读和写作。然后，闪现，八年级。是时候继续前进了。是时候填写一份关于高中衔接的谷歌表格了。
So it's asking for your name. And then go ahead and scroll down to, which color gown do you want to wear at graduation? That's exciting. You get to vote on your gown already.
所以它在问你的名字。然后继续向下滚动，毕业时你想穿什么颜色的长袍？那很令人兴奋。你已经可以投票选长袍了。
Maricela does not look excited.
Maricela看起来并不兴奋。
Apparently, Maricela said she wanted to speak with me, but that was now hard to imagine. She was barely speaking to anyone. I couldn't imagine her feeling comfortable enough to share anything.
显然，Maricela说她想和我谈谈，但现在很难想象了。她几乎没跟任何人说话。我无法想象她能感到自在到分享任何事情。
Do you want to go into-- there's, like, a little office. Or do you rather want to sit here?
你想去——这里有一个小办公室。或者你宁愿坐在这里？
Go in the little office.
去小办公室。
You wanna go in the little office? OK, let me see if Ms. Vanessa can get it for me. Just give me one second.
你想去小办公室？好的，让我看看Vanessa女士能不能给我。给我一秒钟。
A short, agonizing walk through the hall, kids watching us, Maricela intently studying the floor tiles. We get to the room.
穿过大厅的一段短暂、痛苦的行走，孩子们看着我们，Maricela专心地研究地砖。我们到了房间。
Here we go. You can sit right there.
就是这里。你坐在那儿就行。
But then, as soon as we were in this room, I'd barely asked a question-- I said, so I talked to your mom, and then Maricela was telling me about her mom.
但随后，我们一进这个房间，我还没问什么问题——我说，我跟你妈妈谈过了，然后Maricela就开始告诉我关于她妈妈的事。
She helps people, because she even helped this lady. She was, like, 21, and she had a dog.
她帮助别人，因为她甚至帮助过这位女士。她才21岁，有一条狗。
She was our neighbor, but then she got kicked out because the dog was biting the walls. I'd make them food. I'm a really good cook, way better than my sister. Did you know I have a sister? I don't have to go to movement class today, because I have an injury. I have a note. Do you want to see?
她是我们的邻居，但后来因为狗咬墙被赶出来了。我会给她们做饭。我是一个很好的厨师，比我妹妹强多了。你知道我有妹妹吗？我今天不用去运动课，因为我受伤了。我有字条。你想看吗？
I'm scared to play soccer now, because we had a leak at the old apartment. And I, like, messed up my knee. And there's sometimes where my bone just pops out. I, like, just fall.
我现在不敢踢球了，因为旧公寓漏水了。我，弄伤了膝盖。有时我的骨头会蹦出来。我会直接摔倒。
My sister doesn't even help me, Maricela says. Did you know I have a sister? Yeah, she's younger. A brother, too. But the sister's really annoying. When she doesn't get what she wants, she smacks me.
我妹妹甚至不帮我，Maricela说。你知道我有妹妹吗？是的，她是小的。还有个弟弟。但妹妹真的很烦人。当她得不到她想要的东西时，她会打我。
And then, when I told my mom, she says, no, I didn't. And she talks a lot. [CHUCKLES]
然后，当我告诉我妈妈时，她说，没有，我没打。她说话太多了。（轻笑）
Maricela talks a lot about everything. I had assumed when I saw her in the hallway there was no way I was going to get her to tell me what happened. Where was she that whole time? Was she just at home? What'd she do? And what happened with school?
Maricela关于每件事都说了很多。当我看到她在走廊里时，我以为没法让她告诉我发生了什么。那段时间她去哪儿了？她只是在家里吗？她干什么了？学校发生了什么？
OK, so let me ask you about school.
好的，让我问你关于学校的事。
In sixth grade, I went to this school. And then I missed one year of school, because I had to go to Mexico.
六年级时，我去了这所学校。然后我错过了一年，因为我必须去墨西哥。
Why?
为什么？
Huh? Because at that time, it was like my grandma and my grandpa were, like, really sick. And then, being over there, we had to take care of my grandma, my grandpa.
哈？因为那时候，我的奶奶和爷爷病得很重。在那边，我们必须照顾爷爷奶奶。
My grandpa's mom, she had COVID in the same house we lived in. She had COVID, and she was sitting down at her bed when she started, like, hallucinating. And then, she passed away. After that, my grandpa and my grandma got sick.
爷爷的妈妈，她和我们住在一个房子里。她得了新冠，当她开始，比如，产生幻觉时，她坐在床上。然后，她去世了。在那之后，爷爷奶奶也病了。
Maricela and her siblings had to isolate in a room, so they wouldn't get sick too, for weeks.
Maricela和她的兄弟姐妹必须隔离在一个房间里，这样他们就不会病倒，持续了数周。
My mom's oldest sister had to, like, leave the food, like, outside our doors.
我妈妈的大姐必须把食物，放在我们门外。
So you were just living in a room with your siblings, not able to leave the room, getting food delivered to the door?
所以你只是和兄弟姐妹住在一个房间里，不能离开房间，等着食物送到门口？
Yeah. I don't really like it, 'cause I don't like to be, like, locked up.
是的。我真的不喜欢那样，因为我不喜欢被关起来。
And what did you do all day?
你整天都在做什么？
Um, we had to stay in the-- I had a computer over there, a touchscreen computer. I would play Roblox on there, or watch videos, or do whatever I wanted to do. And my sister had her iPad. And I had a TV, and my brother would use the TV.
嗯，我们必须待在——我那边有一台电脑，一台触摸屏电脑。我会在上面玩Roblox，或者看视频，或者做任何我想做的事。我妹妹有她的iPad。我有一台电视，弟弟会用那台电视。
Screens, a lot of screens. Of course. What were millions of missing kids up to when school buildings closed? Playing Roblox. I don't know what I expected. But talking to Maricela and hearing her lay out what happened over those 18 months she was absent from school, it did feel like such an interior, specific view.
屏幕，很多的屏幕。当然。当校舍关闭时，数百万失踪的孩子都在忙什么？玩Roblox。我不知道我期待什么。但和Maricela交谈并听她讲述她在缺席学校的那18个月里发生的事情，确实感觉像是一个如此内在、具体的视角。
I'd been thinking about this as a story of a kid who disappeared from school. But of course, that's not Maricela's story about herself. In Maricela's telling, she didn't disappear, school disappeared.
我一直认为这是一个孩子从学校消失的故事。但当然，那不是Maricela关于她自己的故事。在Maricela的讲述中，她没有消失，学校消失了。
So much of our conversation about schools right now, our ideas about what schools need, what needs to happen to help kids catch up, to get back to normal, usually comes from the perspective of teachers, parents, adults. I want you to hear Maricela's version of this, to hear what it's been like for one of the millions of kids during the pandemic who just stopped attending school-- all the details that matter to her, the stuff that is at eye-level to a kid, stuff adults don't always think to focus on.
我们目前关于学校的对话中，关于我们认为学校需要什么、需要发生什么来帮助孩子赶上进度、恢复正常的所有想法，通常都来自老师、家长和成年人的视角。我想让你们听听Maricela的版本，听听在大流行期间数百万停止上学的孩子之一的经历——所有对她重要的细节，那些处于孩子视线水平的东西，成年人并不总是想到去关注的东西。
It was not a blip for Maricela, it was epic. A lot happened. First, her mom lost her job. Then, her grandparents got sick. And while they were in Mexico, they lost their apartment in Los Angeles. The manager said they'd abandoned it. When they came back to Los Angeles, Maricela's aunt said they could stay with her.
对于Maricela来说，这不是一个“闪现”，这是史诗级的。发生了太多的事情。首先，她妈妈失业了。然后，爷爷奶奶病了。当他们在墨西哥时，他们在洛杉矶的公寓没了。经理说他们遗弃了公寓。当他们回到洛杉矶，Maricela的阿姨说他们可以住在她家。
We all had our schedules, like, who does this, who does that. For example, like, we would wake up, and we would sleep in the living room. We would pick up, we would vacuum the whole living room. We would have to wash the dishes, cook, and then wash those dishes, and broom the kitchen, clean the table after we're done eating, and then clean the bathroom, if it's dirty.
我们都有自己的时间表，谁干这个，谁干那个。例如，我们起床，住在客厅。我们要清理，我们整个客厅都要吸尘。我们要洗碗、做饭，然后洗碗，扫厨房，吃完饭清理桌子，然后清洁卫生间，如果它脏了的话。
Her cousins' kids, though, her aunt's kids-- Maricela says they hardly did anything. She's the oldest in her family. It's her and a younger brother and sister. So a lot of the chores fell to her. It wasn't fair.
她表亲的孩子们，她阿姨的孩子，Maricela说他们几乎什么都不做。她是家里最大的。她还有一个弟弟和一个妹妹。所以大量的家务落在了她身上。这不公平。
And I couldn't tell them anything, because they're snitches. And they told their parents everything about what they do. So I would just ignore it.
我不能告诉他们什么，因为他们是告密者。他们把做什么都告诉了父母。所以我只能忽视它。
It got tense in the apartment. And sometime in the middle of what would have been Maricela's seventh-grade school year, her family moved into their truck. They'd drive to the park she always played at and grab a spot every night. In the daytime, they had a routine. Her younger brother and sister would sleep in the back.
公寓里的气氛变得紧张。在Maricela原本应该是七年级学年的中间某段时候，她家搬进了卡车。他们每天晚上都会开车去她一直玩的公园找个地方停。白天，他们有日常规律。她的弟弟妹妹会在后面睡觉。
They would wake up, like, around 9:00. We would go get breakfast while they were sleeping. We would wake-- we would go park at the park again, and then they would wake up. We would fix the seats, and then they would sit down and eat breakfast.
他们会在9点左右起床。我们在他们睡觉时去买早饭。我们会——我们会再去公园停好车，然后他们会醒来。我们整理好座位，然后他们坐下来吃早饭。
And then, what would happen? What would you do the rest of the day?
然后，发生了什么？那天剩下的时间你做什么？
And then, we would go to my mom's-- to my cousin's house, and we would shower there. We had bathrooms at the park. And to brush our teeth, we'd just brush them like-- we would go to the bathroom, take a water bottle, toothpaste, and my toothbrush, and we would brush them in there.
然后，我们去我妈妈的——我表亲家，在那里洗澡。我们在公园有卫生间。刷牙时，我们就——去洗手间，拿个水瓶、牙膏和牙刷，在里面刷牙。
I talked to Maricela's mom. She confirmed the basics. She lost her job when the pandemic hit, the apartment. They went to Mexico to care for her folks. But she didn't want to do an interview or get into any of this in detail.
我跟Maricela的妈妈聊过。她证实了基本情况。大流行来袭时她失业了，公寓也没了。他们去墨西哥照顾她的父母。但她不想接受采访或深入详细讨论这一切。
So I don't know much about where her head was at or what shaped all the different choices she had to make during that time. She wanted to let Maricela share her experience. When they were staying in the truck, Maricela's mom called LA Family Housing. A caseworker got them a place in a hotel. That's where they're living now.
所以我不知道她的心思在哪里，或者在那段时间里塑造她所做的不同选择的是什么。她想让Maricela分享她的经历。当他们住在卡车里时，Maricela的妈妈给洛杉矶家庭住房中心打了电话。一位个案工作者帮他们在一家酒店找到了住处。那是他们现在住的地方。
And then, the caseworker asked where Maricela wanted to register for school. I don't know if she asked or if she told her she had to. GALS is 40 minutes, in traffic, from the hotel. Maybe somewhere closer, she asked? No, Maricela said. She'd prefer to go back to the school she knows.
然后，个案工作者问Maricela想去哪里注册学校。我不知道她是问她还是告诉她必须去。GALS在交通堵塞时距离酒店有40分钟车程。或者找个近点的地方？不，Maricela说。她宁愿回到她熟悉的学校。
It's funny, when you think about it, that very basic idea that school is where you go as a kid, the thing the rest of life revolves around, it took centuries to establish. It took laws, and social movements, and fiery speeches to establish a sprawling compulsory public education system. But it only took a few months-- weeks, even, with Maricela-- for that idea to be completely undone.
想想看真是有趣，那个最基本的想法——学校是孩子去的地方，是生活围绕运行的东西，它花了几百年才建立起来。它花费了法律、社会运动和火热的演讲才建立起庞大的义务公共教育系统。但它只花了几个月——用Maricela的例子甚至只有几周时间——这个理念就完全被撤销了。
And when it was, when school disappeared from Maricela's life, all the other things-- more immediate, huge dramas-- came in and filled the space. Her mom lost her job. They lived in a truck. She sold candy in the park. Her cousins were snitches. Her family died.
当学校从Maricela的生活中消失时，所有其他事物——更直接、巨大的戏剧——进来了并填补了空间。她妈妈失业了。他们住在卡车里。她在公园卖糖果。她的表亲是告密者。她的家人去世了。
She can talk about all of that for hours. But when I asked Maricela, what about school, she just sort of drifts to some other topic. Not that she doesn't want to talk about it, it almost felt like she didn't remember when the pandemic closed schools. It didn't register.
她可以谈论所有这些长达数小时。但当我问Maricela学校怎么样时，她只是漂移到其他话题上。并不是说她不想谈论它，几乎感觉她记不清大流行什么时候关闭了学校。没注册上。
What did you do in sixth grade when schools closed?
六年级学校关闭时你干什么了？
Um, in sixth grade, when school closed, I didn't finish sixth grade.
嗯，六年级学校关闭时，我没读完六年级。
Why? I would ask, over and over. They closed schools, she'd say. But what about online school? No. Why? I don't know.
为什么？我会一遍又一遍地问。他们关闭了学校，她说。但在线学校呢？不。为什么？我不知道。
It was-- because I wasn't in school at that time.
是因为我那时候没上学。
Why weren't you in school at that time?
那时候你为什么没上学？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Did you want to be in school?
你想上学吗？
No. Because I knew that I couldn't hang out with Valeria.
不想。因为我知道我没法和Valeria一起玩了。
Valeria. Valeria was Maricela's best friend at school. She lived in her building. The vague fog Maricela has when I ask her about school evaporated instantly when the conversation turned to Valeria in sixth grade.
Valeria。Valeria是Maricela在学校最好的朋友。她住在她那栋楼。当我问她关于六年级的事时，Maricela那种模糊的迷雾在谈话转到六年级的Valeria身上时瞬间消失了。
No, I met her-- OK, so when she came from Mexico, she would, like, go to my house a lot. We lived in the same building, and she would go, like, at 6:00 in the morning, and we would come on our way to school together. And we were, like, really close friends that-- this one time, she was knocking at my door, and I opened it, and then we made breakfast together, and then we served--
不，我认识她——好的，当她从墨西哥来的时候，她会经常去我家。我们住在同一栋楼，她会在早上6点去我家，我们一起去学校。我们是非常亲密的朋友——有一次，她在敲我的门，我打开门，然后我们一起做早餐，然后我们准备了——
Maricela became so specific when she talked about Valeria, in that kid way where she's living it in real time, where every detail of a story is shared and assigned exactly equal weight. She knocked. I opened the door. We made breakfast. Here's who came. Here's where we sat. Here's what we ate.
Maricela在谈到Valeria时变得如此具体，用那种孩子般的方式——活在当下，分享每一个故事的每一个细节，并给予完全平等的重视。她敲门。我开门。我们做早餐。谁来了。我们坐在哪。我们吃什么。
--like a tortilla. And then you crack an egg on top. And then, we sliced, like, tomatoes and onions, and we put it on the top. She went to her house, and she got clothes. And she showered in my mom's bathroom while I showered in mine. And then--
——像玉米饼。然后你在上面敲个蛋。然后，我们切西红柿和洋葱放在上面。她去她家拿衣服。她在妈妈的浴室洗澡，我在我的浴室洗澡。然后——
They went out walking, and they ran into Maricela's aunt, who gave her some cash. They went to the store. Maricela snuck to the side and bought something special.
她们走路出去，遇到了Maricela的阿姨，给了她一些现金。她们去商店。Maricela偷偷溜到一边买了特别的东西。
They were, like, little silver hearts that come apart, and they said, "best friends."
它们是那种能分开的小银心，上面写着“最好的朋友”。
Like one of those best-friend hearts, broken heart?
就像那种心碎的最好朋友钥匙扣？
Yeah, but it was like a keychain thing, and we both had it, like, on our backpack. And when we came to the school both together, we were, like, so close. And we would hang out with the other girls, but there was, like, always a space with the other girls.
是的，但这就像一个钥匙扣，我们都在背包上挂着。当我们一起去学校时，我们非常亲密。我们会和其他女孩一起玩，但和其他女孩相处时总是有一点空间。
But me and her were, like, always next to each other. We were, like, really best friends. And then, we would go to the bathroom, and she would wait for me, like, outside the stall. And then she would go in, and I would wait for her.
但我跟她一直挨着。我们是非常好的朋友。然后我们会去洗手间，她会在隔间外等我。然后她进去，我等她。
March 2020, schools closed and upended the lives of millions of families. But again, that's not what Maricela remembers of this time. March 2020, the day before Maricela went to Mexico, what she remembers is that she had a picnic with Valeria at the Valley Plaza Park. Their families came. They ate Pollo Loco.
2020年3月，学校关闭，颠覆了数百万家庭的生活。但再次强调，这不是Maricela记忆中那段时光。2020年3月，Maricela去墨西哥的前一天，她记得是在Valley Plaza公园和Valeria野餐。她们的家人也来了。她们吃了Pollo Loco。
That day, it was her birthday. And I had to tell her that we were leaving. But her brother-- her brother knew before her, but we were supposed to surprise her. But when we were singing Happy Birthday, he told her. And then her eyes got kind of watery.
那天是她的生日。我必须告诉她我们要离开了。但她哥哥——她哥哥比她先知道，我们本打算给她个惊喜。但当我们唱生日快乐歌时，他告诉了她。然后她的眼睛变得有些湿润。
What about you?
你呢？
I wanted to cry.
我想哭。
Did you?
你哭了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Maricela told Valeria she'd see her soon, but she never did. Valeria's family had been trying to make it work in LA, but struggled in those early months of the pandemic, and decided to move back to Ciudad Juarez. That was the last time they saw each other.
Maricela告诉Valeria她很快会再见到她，但她再也没见到。Valeria的家人一直试图在洛杉矶维持生计，但在大流行初期挣扎，决定搬回华雷斯城。那是她们最后一次见面。
How does it feel to walk through the halls now?
现在走在走廊里感觉如何？
OK.
还行。
Knowing what the last year and a half was for Maricela, that it was not a blip, but a long time for a 12-year-old, full of huge experiences, I consider how brave it is what she's doing-- returning to this place that disappeared from her life, coming back after losing family members, her apartment, moving between countries, returning without knowing anything about what she's missed and without Valeria.
知道过去一年半对Maricela意味着什么，这不是一个“闪现”，而是一个12岁孩子经历的漫长时光，充满了巨大的经历，我考虑到她所做的事情是多么勇敢——回到这个从她生活中消失的地方，在失去家人、公寓、国家间搬迁后回来，在不知道错过了什么的情况下回来，而且没有Valeria。
I was nervous, scared. I was like nervous, like, who I will see here. I go to the school, and then I leave. And then I come back, and they just stare at you the whole time. And I get nervous when they stare at me.
我很紧张，害怕。我紧张得想知道我会在这里见到谁。我去学校，然后离开。然后我回来，他们只是盯着你看。他们盯着我看时我很紧张。
You get nervous when they stare at you?
他们盯着你看时你感到紧张？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Yeah.
是的。
It's, like, weird.
这感觉很奇怪。
What does it feel like?
感觉是什么样子的？
It feels like a bunch of cameras watching me.
感觉就像有一堆摄像头在盯着我。
It does kind of seem like that. I watch as Maricela moves through the rest of her school day. She gets a lot of stares. She looks very nervous and very lost.
看起来确实有点那样。我看着Maricela在学校度过剩下的时光。她受到了很多注视。她看起来非常紧张，非常迷失。
People were accusing Hamilton of being what's called a monarchist. Remember King George III?
人们指责汉密尔顿是所谓的“保皇党”。记得乔治三世国王吗？
In history class, the teacher does a lot of, remember when we learned about blah, blah, blah? Like, who can tell me what we know about the monarchy? Who remembers? The elites-- what do we mean by elites? You guys remember? Maricela, of course, does not remember.
在历史课上，老师讲了很多，还记得我们学过的blah blah blah吗？比如，谁能告诉我我们对君主制了解多少？谁记得？精英——我们说的精英是什么意思？你们记得吗？Maricela当然不记得。
OK, so we're going to do quite a bit of reading today. All right. 109, Alabama, is everybody there?
好的，我们今天要做大量的阅读。好的，109，阿拉巴马州，大家都在那儿吗？
In English class, they read a novel written in verse, and then they have to write a response on an online platform. Maricela can't figure out how to submit her response. She's frustrated, but does not ask for help, does not know about the monarchy. She does not know how to use the online learning platform, and she does not speak to anyone.
在英语课上，他们阅读一部诗体小说，然后必须在在线平台上写回复。Maricela没法弄清楚如何提交她的回复。她感到沮丧，但没有寻求帮助，她不知道关于君主制的事。她不知道如何使用在线学习平台，她没有和任何人说话。
She's here. She's finally in the building, but she's still really far away. I felt that deeply, watching her in math. They're playing a game. Everyone has to get up and split it into two groups, but Maricela doesn't move.
她来了。她终于在楼里了，但她依然非常遥远。在数学课上看着她时，我深深地感受到了这一点。他们在玩游戏。每个人都必须站起来分成两组，但Maricela没动。
She's sitting in the back row, and she stays completely still, backpack propped on her desk, looking panicked as the other kids get up and sort themselves into teams. She's wearing a mic clipped to her shirt. She's too far from anyone else for them to hear what she's saying, but I can.
她坐在最后一排，一动不动，背包架在桌子上，当其他孩子站起来分成小组时，她看起来很恐慌。她衣服上夹着一个麦克风。她离其他人太远，他们听不到她在说什么，但我能听到。
[GROANS] My stomach hurts.
（呻吟）我肚子疼。
The teacher notices that Maricela hasn't moved. And for the first time in hours, someone addresses her directly, tells her, you too. Come on.
老师注意到Maricela没动。这是几小时来第一次有人直接跟她说话，告诉她，你也是。来吧。
You, too, pick a group. This one or that one?
你也是，选个组。这个还是那个？
What if I can't play?
如果我不能玩怎么办？
You can play. It's just math.
你能玩。这只是数学。
It's just math, the teacher says. But it is clearly not just math to Maricela. I keep waiting for someone to talk to her, to ask her something. What's going on with you? Where were you? What do you need?
这只是数学，老师说。但这对于Maricela来说显然不仅仅是数学。我一直在等有人跟她说话，问她点什么。你发生什么事了？你去哪儿了？你需要什么？
But school, day-to-day school, is not really set up for that. Her teachers will assess where Maricela is academically. And there's an aide in classes that could help her one-on-one, sometimes. But mostly, school is like this.
但学校，日复一日的学校，并没有为此做好准备。她的老师会评估Maricela学术上的水平。班里有助教可以提供一对一的帮助，有时。但大多数时候，学校是这样的。
This interaction with the math teacher, it lasts 11 seconds. She locks her eyes on Maricela, Maricela shakes her head. And then another kid jumps in front of the teacher, and the room of 25 people moves forward.
这位数学老师的互动，持续了11秒。她盯着Maricela，Maricela摇了摇头。然后另一个孩子跳到老师面前，25个人的房间继续前进。
So I'm going to give you a question. Whoever answers the question first gets to come up here and write there, either their circle or their X. OK?
所以我要给你们一个问题。谁先回答问题，谁就可以上来写，不管是圆还是X。好的？
School is a machine that is designed to move forward. Kids move class-to-class, grade-to-grade. The machine does not stop. It's not designed to go back in time, to meet Maricela where she's at right now, which is at the back of the classroom, hiding behind a backpack, as her classmates enthusiastically compete to solve a math equation.
学校是一个旨在不断向前的机器。孩子从课到课，年级到年级。机器不会停止。它不是为了回到过去而设计的，不是为了在此时此地满足Maricela的，而她现在就在教室后面，躲在背包后面，而她的同学们正热情地竞争解决一道数学题。
[STUDENTS YELLING EXCITEDLY]
（学生兴奋地大叫）
Out of all the awkward moments I saw that day, this one was the hardest to watch, because you can feel the conveyor belt of school moving forward. I could see Maricela's panic that she could not figure out how to jump on.
在那天我看到的所有尴尬时刻中，这一个是观看起来最困难的，因为你能感觉到学校的输送带在向前移动。我能看到Maricela无法弄清楚如何跳上输送带时的恐慌。
And then, I see her try. Right before lunch, Maricela's standing in the hallway nervously digging through her backpack, other kids streaming past her to the lunch tables outside.
然后，我看到她尝试了。就在午饭前，Maricela紧张地在走廊里翻找她的背包，其他孩子从她身边涌向外面的午餐桌。
And then, all of a sudden, she calls out to another kid.
然后，突然之间，她对着另一个孩子喊道。
Arecilli, mira.
She says, Arecilli, look, and opens up her bag. Arecilli is a tall, quiet girl in pink, who's been moving through the whole day in a pack of three-- three girls who, I'm told, have all recently arrived at the school from Mexico. Maricela starts showing Arecilli all the candy, and snacks, and lotion in her backpack.
她说，Arecilli，你看，然后打开了她的包。Arecilli是一个穿粉色衣服、个子高高、安静的女孩，整天都在和另外两个女孩一组——我被告知，她们都是最近刚从墨西哥来到学校的。Maricela开始向Arecilli展示她背包里的所有糖果、零食和乳液。
Oh, look, and I have these. And I have-- look, and I have these. I have Bath and Body Works, too. [LAUGHS]
哦，看，我有这些。还有——看，我有这些。我还有Bath and Body Works的。（大笑）
Now, the three girls are all leaning in over her backpack, giggling and slowly moving through the hall toward lunch up ahead of me. And a sixth-grader quickly replaces Maricela at my side, tells me she's been on TV, so I might recognize her.
现在，三个女孩都凑在她的背包上方，咯咯笑着，慢慢穿过大厅走向午餐，在我前面。一个六年级学生迅速取代了Maricela站在我身边，告诉我她上过电视，所以我也许会认出她。
Have you seen a commercial where a dad's fixing a purple Jeep with his daughter?
你看过一个爸爸和女儿修理紫色吉普车的广告吗？
No. Is that you?
没有。那是你吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You're the daughter?
你是那个女儿？
Yeah. And do you know the show, Henry Danger? OK. [LAUGHS]
是的。你知道《亨利危险》那个节目吗？好的。（大笑）
After disappointing this child star, I spot Maricela outside. She's in line for lunch, and she's with Arecilli and her friends. They're a nervous-looking pack, looking around like something bad could happen, not really talking. But they're a pack. Maricela seems OK for the first time in the whole day, actually, excited.
在让这个童星失望后，我在外面发现了Maricela。她正在排队吃午饭，和Arecilli还有她的朋友在一起。她们是一群看起来很紧张的小团体，四处张望好像坏事会发生一样，并没有怎么说话。但她们是一个团体。Maricela看起来第一次一整天都还好，实际上，很兴奋。
Hanging out with Arecilli-- she's like Valeria.
和Arecilli待在一起——她就像Valeria。
Really?
真的吗？
Mm-hmm. They speak the same.
嗯哼。她们说话一样。
Like, the way that they speak sounds the same?
比如，她们说话的方式听起来一样？
Mm-hmm. And they kind of look the same.
嗯哼。她们看起来也差不多。
Really?
真的吗？
It seems to me like an effort to jump back on the conveyor belt, that Maricela's trying to replicate what she had here before that mattered to her, trying to make a new school friend, who apparently is not dissimilar to her old school friend.
在我看来，这像是跳回输送带的一次尝试，Maricela正试图复制她在这里曾经拥有的重要的东西，试图结交一个新学校朋友，看起来和她以前的学校朋友并没有什么不同。
Arecilli looks like her?
Arecilli看起来像她吗？
Mm-hmm. It was the tall, skinny girl that was with me right now.
嗯哼。就是刚才跟我在一起的那个又高又瘦的女孩。
Do you think you guys will become as close?
你认为你们会变得那么亲密吗？
Mm, I don't know, because, we're already in eighth grade. And then, when she leaves, I'm going to feel alone.
嗯，我不知道，因为，我们已经在八年级了。然后，当她离开时，我会感到孤独。
But you'd have eighth grade together.
但你们会有在一起的八年级。
Mm.
嗯。
So you don't want to become close to her because, after eighth grade, you might not be together anymore?
所以你不想和她变得亲密是因为，八年级之后，你们可能就不在一起了？
Mm-hmm. That's why.
嗯哼。就是这样。
I get it. She can't go back. They can't be as close, because Maricela missed most of middle school. And middle school is almost over. She can't go back to sixth-grade math, just like she can't go back to her apartment.
我明白了。她回不去了。她们不可能那么亲密，因为Maricela错过了大部分初中。而且初中快结束了。她不能回到六年级的数学课，就像她不能回到她的公寓一样。
And she definitely can't go back to Valeria. Everything is moving forward without her. Maricela watches Valeria online now, becoming a teenager without her.
她绝对不能回到Valeria身边。一切都在没有她的情况下向前移动。Maricela现在在线看着Valeria，在没有她的情况下变成了青少年。
I see her, like-- I see her stories, and she looks, like, way different.
我看着她，比如——我看着她的动态，她看起来，完全不同了。
Really?
真的吗？
Like, she had, like, a little bit of freckles here, and they disappeared. And she had, like-- she put a nose piercing on. She's gonna-- I think she's gonna turn, like, 15.
比如，她曾经有一点雀斑，现在消失了。她有——她打了鼻环。我想她要——我想她要15岁了。
What does it feel like to see her looking different?
看到她看起来不同了感觉如何？
Um, it feels weird. She, like, dresses different. She used to wear, like, long sleeves and jeans. And now she wears, like, really ripped jeans. And she wears, like, cropped tops now. Actually, it's like, I miss her.
嗯，感觉很奇怪。她穿得不同了。她以前穿，比如，长袖和牛仔裤。现在她穿，比如，真的很破的牛仔裤。她现在穿露脐上衣。实际上，我，我想她了。
I don't know how schools are going to fit in kids like Maricela. There are so many of them-- not just the millions of kids who have become chronically absent or disappeared entirely, but the tens of millions of kids who fell behind in math and reading, the millions of kids suffering from anxiety, trauma, grief. What happens if they don't fit back in?
我不知道学校该如何容纳像Maricela这样的孩子。她们有很多——不仅仅是数百万长期缺勤或完全消失的孩子，还有数千万在数学和阅读方面落后的孩子，数百万遭受焦虑、创伤、悲伤的孩子。如果她们没法融入回来会怎样？
Maricela has been coming to school for six months now, but she doesn't always come. Her attendance is pretty spotty. Principal Vanessa Garza tells me Maricela is now three grades behind, but she will be promoted to ninth grade.
Maricela来学校已经六个月了，但她不总是来。她的出勤率很不稳定。Vanessa Garza校长告诉我Maricela现在落后三个年级，但她将被升入九年级。
She won't be able to walk at graduation because of the attendance issues, but Ms. Vanessa thinks the shame of being held back would be the end of school for Maricela. And she has a better shot of finishing high school, if she can start earning credits toward graduation now. She'll keep moving forward.
由于出勤问题她没法参加毕业典礼，但Vanessa女士认为留级的羞辱对于Maricela来说将是学校生活的终点。如果她现在能开始赚取通往毕业的学分，她更有机会完成高中。她会继续向前。
I asked Maricela if she likes being back in school. She said, no, but she's going to keep trying.
我问Maricela她喜欢回到学校吗。她说，不喜欢，但她会继续努力。
Our program was produced today by me and Bim Adewunmi and edited by Laura Starecheski. The people who put this show together include Elna Baker, Ben Calhoun, Michael Comite, Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Ira Glass, Seth Lind, Michelle Navarro, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Kyla Jones, Nadia Reiman, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney.
我们今天的节目由我和Bim Adewunmi制作，Laura Starecheski编辑。制作这个节目的团队包括Elna Baker, Ben Calhoun, Michael Comite, Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Ira Glass, Seth Lind, Michelle Navarro, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Kyla Jones, Nadia Reiman, Christopher Swetala和Matt Tierney。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman; senior editor, David Kestenbaum; executive editor, Emanuele Berry. Our consulting editor on today's episode is Rachel Lissy. Special thanks to Jennifer Kottke, Jessica Cerruti, Jenn Gurrera, Koby Levin, and Chalkbeat, Nina Perez at MomsRising, Joshua Kay, Rebecca Vitali-DeCola, Michael K. Barbour, Selena Seay-Reynolds. And many thanks to all the educators and students who spoke with me, including David Eddy, Olivia Defalco, Jaden Varghese, Linda Rost, Twainna Calhoun, Liz Giacovelli, Crystal Thorpe, Regina Grossman, Teresa Hill, and everyone at GALS, especially Principal Vanessa Garza, and Ms. Mayra Olivarez.
我们的主编是Sarah Abdurrahman；高级编辑，David Kestenbaum；执行编辑，Emanuele Berry。今天这一集的咨询编辑是Rachel Lissy。特别感谢Jennifer Kottke, Jessica Cerruti, Jenn Gurrera, Koby Levin和Chalkbeat，MomsRising的Nina Perez, Joshua Kay, Rebecca Vitali-DeCola, Michael K. Barbour, Selena Seay-Reynolds。还要非常感谢所有与我交谈的教育工作者和学生，包括David Eddy, Olivia Defalco, Jaden Varghese, Linda Rost, Twainna Calhoun, Liz Giacovelli, Crystal Thorpe, Regina Grossman, Teresa Hill，以及GALS的所有人，特别是Vanessa Garza校长和Mayra Olivarez女士。
Our website is ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站是ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以完全免费地在线收听我们超过700集的档案。《美国生活》由公共广播交换机构PRX提供给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass. He's out this week, because he's trying to branch out from radio and make it onto the US gymnastics team, 2024 Olympics. But I'm a little worried he's making a lot of enemies at the tryouts.
一如既往感谢我的老板Ira Glass。他这周不在，因为他正试图从广播转向进军美国体操队，参加2024年奥运会。但我有点担心他在选拔赛上树敌太多。
[LAUGHS] Oh, you're doing cartwheels? OK.
（大笑）哦，你在做侧手翻？OK。
I'm Chana Joffe-Walt. Ira will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Chana Joffe-Walt。Ira下周会回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。